hello I'm suna Kazi shihara from the
Pokemon company Pokemon cafe mix was
just released today I hope you're all
enjoying today I would like to tell you
about a new project we have been working
on to begin please take a look at this
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm happy to announce the first
strategic team-based Pokemon battle game
Pokemon unite we have partnered with ten
cent to develop this game and I would
like to invite Steven mah from 10 cents
to tell you more Steven Steven it's all
yours mr. Ishihara thank you for the
kind introduction hello everyone I'm
Steven muffin ten cent as a Pokemon fan
myself I'm really happy to be able to
announce this project the unite in
Pokemon unites represents the gameplay
concept of players coming together with
a shared goal through our shared pursuit
of innovative gameplay and qualities 10
cent and the Pokemon company have united
with the goal of creating a new game
that could be enjoyed by others at 10
cent games we are committed to our
search for undiscovered potential in
game development and this also hunts
true in our partnership with the Pokemon
this is why we have assigned Timmy
Studios a team with 11 years of game
development experience that has worked
on many hit titles to this project I am
confident that this collaboration
between two studios and the Pokemon
company Tim is sure to spark new
creativity and bring about own gameplay
experience and surprise and delight
Thank You Steven thank you very much
the development concept behind Pokemon
unite was to create a cooperative
Pokemon game that anyone could pick up
and enjoy immediately it also has a lot
of depth to be played over and over
again 10 cent games
Timmy Studios specializes in team-based
battle gears and we have fused that with
Pokemon to create an all new experience
in Pokemon unite next I would like to
have the producer of Pokemon unite
mr. Hoshi knows show more of the game to
you all I'm Misaki Hoshino from the
Pokemon company producer of Pokemon
unite allow me to go over some of the
basics the biggest defining trait of the
game is its real-time team battles
featuring the most Pokemon scene in a
single battle yet with two teams of five
Pokemon each
players team up and cooperate together
to defeat the opposing team this is the
layout of the battle arena your team
side is on the left while your
opponent's side is on the right on each
team's side there are a total of five
goals or scoring areas catch wild
Pokemon that inhabit the field to score
points the goal of the game is to score
more points than your opponents within
the time limit the Pokemon you control
begins each battle at level 1 by
defeating wild Pokemon in the field your
Pokemon will increase in level and you
can evolve as well as learn new moves
you get to choose which moves your
Pokemon learns as it levels up focus on
close-range attacks or choose to
optimize for long-range capabilities
even with the same Pokemon you can
choose how you want to battle once you
reach a high enough level you can unlock
moves unique to this game called unite
moves some can deal a lot of damage to
multiple opponents at once each Pokemon
has a different unite move with powerful
effects choosing when to use your unite
mode and attempting to read when the
opponent will use theirs is part of the
excitement of the match use tactics like
surrounding opponents that approach your
base or sneaking around back to the
opponent's side's goal to score while a
teammate has the opponent's attention
teamwork is very important in order to
defeat your opponents to make it easier
for players to enjoy battling with
others and Pokemon unite we will be
releasing it as a free to start game for
Nintendo switch and mobile devices the
game will also support cross-platform
play I hope you will look forward to the
release of pokemon unite
since this is the first strategic
team-based Pokemon battle game I imagine
some of you may be wondering how the
game will actually play well I'd like to
show you some gameplay with ten players
here is the group will be joining my
team and here can you who are you sure
come on boyo I'm going to focus on
playing so I'll turn it over to our two
commentators I'm Corey and I'll be your
commentator for today's match and I have
the producer of the game mr. Hoshino
here to to provide commentary Thanks I'm
happy to join you and with that let's
get the match started now our players
are choosing their Pokemon while there
are no type advantages in Pokemon unite
each Pokemon has different traits and
abilities so your choice is important
both teams have locked in their Pokemon
picks
yeah Ganga wine the battle begins is all
the Pokemon rush out from the starting
area as we can see our players are
catching lots of wild Pokemon and we
have our first score of the game team
customer stop mr. Ishihara squirtle has
evolved into a Wartortle his HP is
running very low if you would treat to a
goal on your side you can recover your
HP talonflame has its sights on Pikachu
Pikachu couldn't get away and talonflame
got the KO even if your Pokemon is
knocked out it will recover after a
brief amount of time Snorlax is trying
to score a goal with the opposing teams
clefable
and talonflame are trying to put a stop
to it if you get attacked while trying
to score you will be interrupted
Charmeleon is in trouble being chased
down by three opponents and here comes
mr. Ishihara swore turtle with a skull
bash in hydro pump combo what an amazing
play they expertly surrounded their
opponents the goal was destroyed with
the goal destroyed the opponents have
fewer healing spots
and here comes a unite move talonflame
is knocked out and Charizard unleashes a
Fire Blast
[Music]
we're approaching the end of the match
with Team Ishihara in the lead the whole
points scored in the final two minutes
are doubled there's no telling who will
end up winning this match tomorrow has a
lot of points saved up and he's sending
his Charizard in for a goal and he
scores a massive score for the team this
might decide the match as we near the
end of the match we see mr. Ishihara
team approaching the goal on the
opponent's side and here is Snorlax with
the unite men blast away unleashing a
unite move of its own they are
overwhelming that venusaur only 10
seconds left on the clock now canteen
Ishihara doing
and that's the game mr. Ishii hores team
are the winners I didn't know who was
going to win right up until the very end
what a thrilling battle as you could see
it took a lot of teamwork to emerge
victorious thanks to all of our players
and commentators today we are hard at
work on Pokemon unite to make it a game
that we hope all of you will love we
look forward to sharing more details in
the future about when we plan to launch
the game thank you again for tuning in
today
[Music]
you